María clara muy buenos días comenzó con
la conferencia bitcoin en junio 2021 en
la ciudad de Miami donde el presidente
nayim bukele sorprendió a todos los
asistentes y a la comunidad
internacional con este anuncio de que el
Salvador sería el primer país soberano
del mundo en adoptar esta criptomoneda
Como una moneda de curso en legal a la
par con el dólar su argumento fue el de
incluir financieramente al 70% de los
salvadoreños que no contaban con cuenta
bancaria que trabajaban desde la
economía informal La promesa fue la de
una Revolución económica una iniciativa
que fue completamente respaldada por la
mayoría de oficialista en el congreso
pero contó con todo el rechazo de el
fondo monetario Internacional del Banco
Mundial de miles de salvadoreños que
salieron a las calles en septiembre a
protestar contra todos los pronósticos
nayib bukele el 6 de septiembre 2021
compró las primeras 400 monedas de
bitcoin y un día después el 7 de
septiembre es decir hace un año
exactamente El Salvador comenzó a tener
el bitcoin Como una moneda legal Y cómo
evolucionó la valorización del bitcoin
brevemente
bueno las primeras 400 monedas costaron
cada una 52 mil dólares en noviembre del
2021 por una sucesión de excelentes
noticias para las criptomonedas el
bitcoin alcanzó su máximo histórico 69
mil dólares los pronósticos serán
esperanzadores toda una felicidad que
hizo que el propio bukele prometiera
construir una ciudad bitcoin pero en
mayo de este año sobre todo en junio
llegó el cripto invierno se desplomó el
bitcoin por debajo de los 20 mil dólares
y de los 2.381 bitcoins que hasta ahora
El Salvador ha comprado ella se
presentan pérdidas del
55%, se han quitado todos los avisos en
las calles y el bitcoin Parece ser una
realidad que no ha cumplido las
expectativas